major breaking news in the continuing
scandal there's really no other word for
it involving Donald Trump and Russia
recalled that former Trump national
security adviser Michael Flynn was
forced to resign I believe it was early
last week in shame just a few weeks into
the Trump administration because it was
revealed that he had lied about the
nature of his contacts with the Russian
ambassador to the US during a time
before Trump's inauguration including
having had discussions about Russian
sanctions this bolstered the case that
funny stuff is going on with Russia and
the Trump administration it led to calls
for a special prosecutor and a broader
investigation both things that many
Republicans have rejected truly
embarrassing sad low-energy
but that is not it it's worse it is now
surfaced that Donald Trump's Attorney
General Jeff Sessions was also in touch
with the Russian ambassador during the
election and he also appears to have
lied about it
put your seat belts on get the kids out
of the room it's getting bad twice last
year Jeff Sessions spoke with the
Russian ambassador according to Justice
Department officials his own staff and
did not disclose either encounter when
asked about possible contacts between
members of Trump's team and Russian
representatives imagine that hey did any
Trump people have contact with Russia
mr. sessions no none oh I mean me but no
nobody at all right in the middle of
what we now know to have been Russia's
cyber campaign to help Donald Trump win
the election Jeff Sessions had a meeting
with Russian ambassador Sergey kis lyac
in sessions his own office and of course
the lies lies lies here's video from
Jeff Sessions is January 10th
confirmation hearing where senator Al
Franken asked a very straightforward
question what would you do if you
learned of any evidence that anyone
affiliated with the Trump campaign
communicated with the Russian government
during the 2016 campaign Jeff Sessions
opting to volunteering that he didn't
have any contact with any Russian
officials we now know that to be untrue
if it's true it's obviously extreme
serious and if there is any evidence
that anyone affiliated with the Trump
campaign communicated with the Russian
government in the course of this
campaign what will you do
senator Franken I'm not aware of any of
those activities I have been called a
surrogate at a time or two in that
campaign and I didn't have not have
communications with the Russians and I'm
unable to comment very well I'm not
aware he said I mean I did it myself but
I don't know of anyone who did this and
I certainly did Jeff Sessions was under
oath at this time if you can prove both
intent will intent as the key aspect of
this and that there was a false
statement made that is called perjury a
felony that provides for a prison
sentence of up to five years more on
that later but it wasn't just once
senator Patrick Leahy during these
confirmation hearings of Jeff Sessions
submitted questions in writing two
sessions one of those questions think
you know where I'm going with this was
have you been in contact with anyone
connected to any part of the Russian
government about the 2016 election
either before or after election day
sessions responded with a single word
answer it was a two letter word that
word was no now justice officials are
defending this on the basis of a
technicality they're saying well yes
sessions was a Trump surrogate at the
time and yes he met with the Russian
ambassador but he met with the Russian
ambassador not as a trump surrogate but
as a member of the Armed Services
Committee justice officials are also
defending this by saying hey he is after
all on the Armed Services Committee
totally normal to meet with the Russian
ambassador
however as Steve Ginsburg from the
Washington Post tweeted earlier today no
one else on the Senate Armed Services
Committee met with the Russian
ambassador so if it's completely normal
Pat for someone from that committee to
meet with the Russian ambassador why was
Jeff Sessions the only guy to do it
there's so many other things that could
make this less sketchy yeah for example
if he also met with France in UK and
South Africa for example or if other
members
this committee had also met with the
Russians that also would make it less
sketchy not only did he do it he also
lied about it this is the top lawyer in
the country he should know that's
clearly perjury and if if he's going to
rest on the technicality that he didn't
meet with anyone from Russia for
anything related to the campaign if
you're going to be at the time he was
going to be the top lawyer of the United
States and you can't think about how
answering the way you answered on the
basis of that semantic game that's not
necessarily who I want as the top lawyer
of the United States and this makes it
much harder to believe that this meeting
was about something not related to the
campaign because again as I said as Pat
said nobody else met with the Russian
ambassador and sessions did not really
meet with other ambassadors either it's
not even a simple live the simple lie
he knew about someone meeting with
Russians but lied here it was him who
met with Russians and said he doesn't
know of anybody having met with Russians
many Democrats calling for resignation
including congresswoman Nancy Pelosi you
have other Democrats and Republicans
calling for Jeff Sessions to recuse
himself from the investigation into
contact between crump and Russia think
about how insane this has gotten you
still have people saying hey I don't
know anything
Trump Russia it doesn't make any sense
to me you have an investigation into
contacts between Trump and Russia and
the guy running the department involved
in the investigation lied about his own
contacts with Russia while he was a
surrogate of the Trump campaign and
Trump still claims that his
administration is a well-oiled machine
yeah I mean yeah first it was Michael
Flynn now we're learning about Trump's
personal lawyer Michael Cohen and then
there's people who just blatantly have
ties to Russia don't even hide it Paul
Manafort his old campaign manager and
Rex Tillerson his Secretary of State his
Secretary of State made a career on
contacts with Russia
it's not even there's not even any
question about it if you thought before
that we didn't need a special prosecutor
because Jeff Sessions as Attorney
General was going to look into this for
us now that sessions is involved and
appears to have lied are we now ready to
say we eat a special crop prosecutor and
if not now then when
will we ever see perjury charges against
sessions I say absolutely not you need
both
you need to prove both that the
individual in question made a false
statement while under oath plus you need
to prove intent and it's very tough to
do especially when you're talking about
senators members of an administration
who can say listen at the time it was
the best of my recollection and
obviously think about what we've heard
from sessions first he was he said no I
had no meetings then he said oh I do
remember the meetings but I don't
remember what we talked about and now
all of a sudden he remembers that they
didn't talk about anything related to
the campaign if this continues to blow
up that will probably be the defense Pat
which is sessions misspoke misunderstood
the question or didn't remember the
details at the time but I mean he just
said no flat out in writing usually
these lawyers are smart enough to say to
the best of my recollection to the best
of my knowledge he didn't preface it
with any of that yeah to the bet yeah
that's that's a common one as far as I
can currently remember senator no I did
not have any any such meetings what an
absolute and utter scandal and people
still I'm still talking to people who
email me you're on Reddit online Twitter
etc who say David I genuinely don't
think that the Russian hacking
influenced the election that's not the
Russia story now that the actual hacking
and whether it impacted the election is
5% of the entire story now given
everything that's come up and I'm I'm
repeatedly telling people Pat if you're
only thinking about the hacking part the
story has gone so far beyond that at
this point we've have to reach the
collusion angle I think until we get to
the actual bombshell here but the pieces
are in place I mean the writing's on the
wall at this point I used to say drip
drip drip it's more now like a
free-flowing faucet I don't think it's a
high flow showerhead now that it's no
longer a drip